While the Cold War with the Soviet
Union was a nuclear arms race,
the Cold War with China is
being fought in digital space.
In late August, Washington restricted
sales of sophisticated chips
to China and Russia. (August 26 - informed NVIDIA)
The two top Silicon Valley chip designers,
NVIDIA and Advanced Micro Devices, have been
told to limit sales of their high-end chips
known as graphics processing units or GPUs.
GPUs were originally developed
to render images in video games
but are now used in supercomputers that recognize
speech and identify objects in photographs.
In other words, they can be used for
artificial intelligence gathering.
The People’s Daily, the mouthpiece
of China’s Communist Party,
claimed on its Twitter account that the country’s
facial recognition system could scan the faces
of China’s 1.4 billion citizens in just one
second. And by the way, this tweet was in 2018.
NVIDIA, the largest GPU maker by far, confirmed
that the U.S. federal government now requires
the company to seek export licenses
to sell two types of high-end chips:
the A100 and the upcoming H100, and any
future chips equivalent in performance.
For AMD, the affected chip is the MI250.
These processors help “accelerate” the most
intensive parts of machine learning used in AI.
In an SEC filing, NVIDIA revealed that
the U.S. government fears there is a risk
that the products “may be used in or diverted
to a “military end use” in China and Russia.
Both companies do not currently sell to Russia.
NVIDIA’s statement indicates it does not
expect licenses to be granted in most cases
and could take a $400 million
dollar hit this quarter.
Beijing is clearly not happy
about the restrictions.
A Chinese foreign ministry official said the U.S.
is trying to impose a “technological blockade” on
China and that the restrictions show America is
trying to maintain its “technological hegemony”.
Reuters quoted the U.S. Department of Commerce
as saying the restrictions are meant to "keep
advanced technologies out of the wrong hands.”
These restrictions come shortly after the Biden
administration offered billions in subsidies
to a Taiwanese company IF it agrees not to sell
its most advanced semiconductor chips to China.
Taiwan Semiconductor Manufacturing
Company makes the most advanced
chips for nearly every company on
earth, including Nvidia and AMD.
Although TSMC has factories
in China and one in the U.S.,
its most advanced factories are in
Taiwan…for security reasons. I did
a story about the importance of TSMC
which I’ll link in my description.
TSMC is now building a $12 billion dollar
factory in Arizona so it’s no surprise that
Arizona’s governor Doug Ducey is the latest
American politician to cozy up to Taiwan.
He flew there to meet with
Taiwanese President Tsai Ing-wen.
Chinese firms are making their own semiconductor
chips, though they are a generation or two
Not to mention in 2019, the
Trump administration lobbied
the Dutch government to block the
shipment of cutting-edge machines
that are an essential component in printing
chips for TSMC and other chipmakers.
The Dutch firm ASML is the only company in the
world making the $150 million dollar machines
that pattern the finest lines
on the most advanced chips.
The Biden administration has been pushing ASML to
stop shipping even its less sophisticated systems
to China, which would seriously hurt Chinese firms
that are producing their own semiconductor chips.
These new U.S. restrictions
involving Nvidia and AMD
are another attempt to hamper
China’s technological capabilities.
Without integrated units from those
two companies, Chinese firms will
find it more difficult to implement advanced
computing for speech and image recognition.
These processors are commonly
found in smartphones,
for example, to identify people in photos.
However, they also have military uses.
Such as scouring satellite imagery
for weapons or military bases.
Or listening to communications and monitoring
faces for intelligence-gathering purposes.
Washington has argued that products
sold in the Chinese marketplace are
ending up in the hands of the Chinese military.
For example, Nvidia and Intel sold
chips to Sugon, a Chinese firm that
makes computers for various companies but
also supplies them to the Chinese military.
A report in 2020 by the New York Times
raised concerns that these chips are
powering a supercomputing center that
conducts mass surveillance in China’s
northwestern Xinjiang province to track
Uighurs and other Muslim minorities.
Both Intel and Nvidia told the Times
they were unaware of what they called
the misuse of their technology.
In 2016, a Chinese police surveillance project
called Sharp Eyes had the ambitious plan of
being able to monitor 100% of all public spaces
in China by 2020 - even the vast rural areas.
There is no word on how far they’ve
come in achieving this goal.
Although the blockade is meant
to prevent American technology
from being used by America’s military
rival, AI chips have wide applications.
Companies like Alibaba,
Baidu, and Tencent use them in their data
centers to process large volumes of data.
Now, they’ll have to make do with
lower-performance GPUs that could slow them down.
So, there are broader implications for society.
Or, perhaps, it is inevitable that
China will begin producing its own
high-end GPUs and become self-reliant.
It may only be a matter of time.
The people who are shaping our future have
a deep understanding of how the world works
which is why brushing up on your math, science,
and computer science skills is essential.
That’s why I trust Brilliant
which helps you improve your STEM
skills through learning interactively.
I know my viewers especially love their
Computer Science Fundamentals course.
In this course, you have to
deliver mail to every house
on the street using as few commands as possible.
You can solve puzzles with science
through their Scientific Thinking course.
Or practice Everyday Math by
seeing numbers in a new light.
There’s something for everyone.
For me, I’m continuing to enjoy
their Logic courses which are
helping to improve my critical thinking skills.
There are no tests, and Brilliant is for people
of all experience levels - whether
you’re a student or already working.
It’s FREE for you to try out if you head
to the custom link in my description:
brilliant.org/newsthink
And the first 200 people who sign up with my
link will get 20% off Brilliant’s annual Premium
subscription which gives you access to all of the
offerings including the most advanced courses.